ACOUPLE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VEGAS.
THE BRK TRIES TO
CENTER GOES ALL
THE WAY ACROSS.
PASTRNAK ENTRIES, P
WITH A MOVE FIVE
FEET OTHER THE BLUE
LINE.
NINIHERE IS WILLIAM
KARLSSON,
MARCHESSAULT CATCH
OFFICIAL AUTO
INSURANCE PROGRAM
OF THE BOSTON
BRUINS.
IT TO
HALL, LALAON THE
DEFLECTION, TIPPED
IN FRONT.
TATION BY
VEGAS IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
HIS BACK IT
GETS THROUGH.
>> JacPIVOTS, PAS
MARCHESSAULT, A
GOOD POKE CHECK.
MAX PACIORETTY HAS
WHAT A PASS.
-- STEPHENSON PAST
MOORE INTO THE
CORNER.
OUT,
DEFLECTION AND IT'S
GONNA COUNT.
THE CALL ON THE ICE
IS GOOD GOAL.
STICK,
OFF THE SKATE
BLADE, BEHIND
MIDDLE,  THE SHOT
SCORES. IF THERE
IS OBSTRUCTIONONWHI
IDEAL POSITION TO
HAND THIS WILL
PUCK.
KOLESAR TO DADONOV
OFF THE SKATE. ndy:
FOR THE PUCK. T
>> Andy: WELL, IN
>> Andy: WELLLLTO
PLAY TOGETHER WITH
BERGERON, GIVE DONE
LINEUP THAT MCNABB
MOORE